alors les yoles seront elles sur l'eau
cette année
comme chaque année depuis trente six ans
avant avant de vous répondre sur cette
question précise
effectivement si les matinées qu'elles
veulent aujourd'hui espérer revoir les
yoles évolué sur les plans d'eau de
martinique il était important que les
règles du confinement soir soit
respectée martiniquais nous sommes
touchés par un virus locaux vides de 19
qui infecte des martiniquais qui tue
démenti nick est malheureusement et
aujourd'hui il est important que nous
puissions respecter les règles de
confinement et qu'on évite de se
rencontrer
justement laguiole est un un beau
mouvement le mouvement martiniquais mais
qui fait de très fort aux regroupements
de population et à ce moment là on était
obligé de donc de trancher
je suis deux opérations la première qui
est donc le championnat japonais de
martinique
il faut rappeler que le président de la
république a pour l'instant mis en place
une condition confinement jusqu'au 11
mai avec une interdiction de réaliser
des opérations d'envergure ou au 15
juillet donc automatiquement notre
championnat en lui-même on l'a arrêté
les deux championnats sus de celui des
bébés hall et puis celui des guignols
et puis il a fallu effectivement
réfléchir autour du hall concernant le
tour des yoles plus personne l'aller
nous avons trois politique la première
c'est le kobe 19 ans quel état sera la
martinique en juin juillet et août
comment on sera est ce qu'on sera plus
touché est quoi plus de personnes
infectées personne de c est à partir de
ça nous disions déjà obligé de
d'imaginer ne pas réaliser le tout dans
les conditions dans lesquelles ils se
déroulent habituellement
deuxième problème que nous avons sur le
problème de l'organisation problèmes
organisationnels les villes aujourd'hui
les meilleurs ne sont pas véritablement
en place sont les mets ont été élus mais
disposer l'ancien conseils municipaux
ils n'ont pas encore de budget et quel
est le meilleur qui va d'emblée accepté
de regrouper vingt mille personnes sur
son territoire comme ça ça ne sera pas
évident à négocier
et puis seul aspect financier il faut
pas se cacher là dessus c'est un million
d'euros à trouver
même s'il a des soutiens publics ni à
des soutiens privés et on connaît l'état
des entreprises aujourd'hui donc
justement de graves conséquences
économiques derrière cette décision
cette décision d'annulation
oui on obligeait de pour l'instant 2
en tout cas le tout dans sa forme
aujourd'hui il va pas se réaliser et
nous avons nous étions réunion au
conseil d'aministration hier soir j'ai
tenu une vision confiance assez longue
cet après midi très explicative est très
porteuse d'idées avec tous les
présidents
cet après midi on a convenu qu'on
comporterait notre trou on ne ferait pas
il ceci au nom de la protection de la
population de martinique quand vous
dites le tout le tour dans sa forme ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que vous
avez imaginé autre chose on peut
imaginer autre chose
il ya eu des idées ont été émises par
les présidents mais aujourd'hui le
problème c'est qu'on ne peut on peut on
est obligé de limiter notre imagination
parce qu'on ne sait pas à quoi on va
être mangé je vais dire toi guillemets
par le coc u19
donc ça sera peut être aussi une
opération d'envergure qui sera lancée
dans les mois à venir pour pouvoir
relancer d'autres saisons éventuellement
très bien merci beaucoup alain richard
je rappelle que vous êtes président de
la fédération des yoles rondes de
martinique